in this lecture we start our systematic
study of Bayesian inference we will
first talk a little bit about the big
picture about inference in general the
huge range of possible applications and
the different types of problems that one
may encounter for example we have
hypothesis testing problems in which we
are trying to choose between a finite
and usually small number of alternative
hypothesis or estimation problems where
we want to estimate as close as we can
and unknown numerical quantity we then
move into the specifics of Bayesian
inference the central idea is that we
always use the Bayes rule to find the
posterior distribution of an unknown
random variable based on observations of
a related random variable depending on
whether the random variables are
discrete or continuous we must of course
use the appropriate version of the Bayes
rule if we want to summarize the
posterior in a single number that is to
come up with a numerical estimate of the
unknown random variable we then have
some options one is to report the value
at which the posterior is largest
another is to report the mean of the
conditional distribution these go under
the acronyms map and LMS we will see
shortly what these acronyms stand for
given any particular method for coming
up with a point estimate there are
certain performance metrics that tell us
how good the estimate is for hypothesis
testing problems the appropriate metric
is the probability of error the
probability of making a mistake for
problems of estimating a numerical
quantity an appropriate metric that we
will be using a lot is the expected
value of the squared error as you will
see there will be no new mathematics in
this lecture just a few definitions a
few new terms and an application of the
Bayes rule nevertheless it is important
to be able to apply the Bayes rule
systematically and with confidence for
this reason we will be going over
several example